well
[Music] they
arrest an nfl player in las
vegas' after having played in the
probo how are you greetings cristian
cásseres as reported by the metropolitan police they
arrested the
young player camarón who plays for the
new orleans saints team after  a
fight that broke out in a nightclub
on Sunday left one person
severely injured and hospitalized
camera but posted his bail and is
scheduled to appear before a
judge Monday afternoon two vigils were held
over the weekend to
remember  to the victims of the apparent
clash last weekend in north
las vegas on sunday night a
group of people gathered in front of the
statue of civil rights
activist martin luther king junior to
pay tribute to the family of
zacarías who lost  seven members
of his family
the governor styps slyke the mayor of
our fairs were among the
dignitaries who were present at
the v  igilia
y la fe de desportes de artes marciales
better known as garcia announced the
expansion of its facilities to the
southwest of the valley plans for the
project received a green light
last week would include
fast food outlets shops and even
eleit restaurants ex del ajax and located
Near Rainbow Streets and the 215 Freeway, it
also has plans to upgrade its
facilities for special events
like fights and concerts,
and the public is reminded that
government-sent Haiti Five face masks are already being
distributed in pharmacies and
community centers.  Throughout the valley, it
is worth mentioning that all sites have a
supply of face masks, so
the public is asked to call first,
each resident can receive up to three
masks completely free and
we start the week with
higher temperatures than normal, as we can
see, we will have days  in the mid
sixties and will quickly rise in s  us
digits at seventy the next few days
will look like those of spring
and this pleasant wave will continue until
next week I am cristian cásseres with
his cold informative Spanish news now
good day
[Music]